the Joe Rogan experience fine Cerrone
isn't he oh yeah yeah yes yeah a couple
days so yeah today's Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday yeah
who do you think I do not know my friend
no I never predict fights because I
think he might feel disrespectful if we
were alone I would tell you my thoughts
mmm no but not in this one in this in
this one I feel like this is a
legitimate fifty-fifty property yeah
yeah same I don't need a warrior both
warriors could go either way
well also skill-wise yeah look at the
sky look at a bunch of different things
so look at damage Age skill motivation
and then like past results going all
these things yeah when you look at all
those things you you give Connor a
slight advantage with stand up like with
his speed he's very explosive and he
tends to knock guys out like not
left-handed left has a piss so explosive
it tends to catch guys with a lot of
explosive punches yeah very fast whereas
cowboy is more of a steady pace wears on
you but can also finish head kick yeah
has the most finishes in UFC history
most submissions I believe he has the
motivation records doesn't he a lot of
Records yeah a lot of records against
you know he's fought nothing but tough
guys like for a long [ __ ] time and
head kick it and strangle and tough guys
how old is he now cowboy I think is 36
36 yeah and Connor I think it's 31 is it
yeah so right is it so I think 31 makes
sense
Connor has less miles on them for sure
but Cowboys never looked better than
he's had over the last few years and you
give him a fight where you can really
get up and this is a fight where it's
like oh really I mean this is the red
panties night you know Connor always
talks about wrestling is it yeah
everybody's gonna tune into that fight a
jelly giant fight it's a giant prop and
it's also an interesting fight because
even though both guys are not title
holders yeah it's still a five-round
fight that has the same super fight feel
that any other world title I would have
yeah you want to see that fight it does
the world title I've been arguing this
forever isn't very important it's always
good to know come
Morrow whose mom is the best 170 pounds
fighter in the world it's proven because
he has the world title and he yeah they
would beat Woodley and then he beat Coco
yeah I agree that that's important but I
also agree that that's not required for
a great fight what's required is a great
matchup and this is a great matchup this
to me is a pay-per-view batch up like I
mean I am that could genuinely go either
way as well and I'm working the event
but if I wasn't working the event I'd be
like what is happening here yeah how
does that go down yeah how does that go
down you know I don't know how it goes
down it might be Connor
tries to catch him real quick with a
straight left it might be cowboy takes
him down it might be cowboy tries to
kick his legs on the outside it might
you know it might be you know Connor
takes a slower approach because he
thinks that cowboy strategy is for him
to wear himself out in the first round
so maybe Connor fights light light and
easy in the first yeah maybe he looks to
prove a point
you know who to go the long run just in
case well not just that he has gone he's
gone heavy as he bolt up more so third
fourth fifth round it's gonna be
struggling joints wise it could be he
could also I don't think so he's I don't
think he's bulked up as much as he's not
cutting weight right I mean to you
starving himself to make 145 155 is more
comfortable for him 175 is no weight
cutting so I think he's probably gonna
be walking around just a little bit over
that I know Donald is Donald I think
Donald in the video said he was walking
around somewhere around 177 178 so
that's not yeah that's nothing that's a
day in the sauna and Don's on weight
yeah and then cowboy just rehydrates and
he's good to go and he's done it a
hundred times he's oh yeah he's well
he's better I think he's better
physically like without the drain you
know and I think size-wise he's better
as a 55 because those big giant guys
like Darren till at 170 you're just a
little bit too much a little bit too
powerful like but I think that at 170
with Conor at 170 they're both guys were
55 pounds they're just not cutting
weight Kelly yeah so there's no I don't
think there's an advantage for either
one
[Applause]